-Hey there, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
Each night this week, we have
turned the open of our show over
to "Late Night" writer
Amber Ruffin
to tell personal stories of her
experiences with the police,
and here's one more.
-For the past three days,
we have opened "Late Night"
with me telling a story
about run-ins with the cops.
And tonight, I'm out of stories.
Just kidding.
I have more.
A few years ago, I'm in the car
with my white friend.
He is a white man in a suit.
He's just gotten off of work.
Now, I'm in a head-to-toe
velvet outfit because I'm great.
I think I was going to a party,
so it was like
my favorite party outfit.
I still remember that thing.
It was beautiful.
It was not that late at night.
So, we're at a truck stop,
seeing if my friend's dad,
who is a truck driver, is there.
We're driving slowly
along the semitrucks,
looking
for his dad's license plate.
So I can see why
we may have seemed suspicious.
And a cop comes up,
and he taps on the window.
And I'm like, "Frick!"
I have been harassed
for doing nothing.
I'm sure this guy
is going to get us.
My friend rolls down the window,
and the cop is super nice.
Now, I had never been stopped
by a cop
while a white man was around.
And the respect this cop had
for this white man
in this suit, man, I --
this cop wants to know
what in the world we are doing,
and he asked politely.
And we tell him,
and he is unsatisfied.
He goes, "I stopped you
because there's been
a lot of prostitution."
[ Laughing ] And I go,
"Oh, I'm not a prostitute."
And this cop has never believed
anything less.
He looks at our I.D.s,
and he asks us more questions.
And my white friend
is getting annoyed at this cop.
And the cop can tell.
But I'm like,
"Oh, my gosh, please
just calm down and be cool."
My friend says to the cop --
he goes,
"You have nothing.
You have to let us go."
And I'm like,
"You just got me killed!"
But the cop goes...
[Sighs]
"Okay, but you have to leave."
[ Laughing ] Ok--
And then that was it.
My friend was like,
"She's not a prostitute!"
And I was like, "Oh, shut up.
Hey, we're going.
Thank you. Goodbye."
Y'all, the respect this cop
just automatically had
for my friend --
I'll never forget seeing it.
So, that's it.
That's my story.
Alright.
So, for the past 10 days,
the George Floyd protests
were worldwide.
Like, hundreds of thousands
of people
all over the country,
all over the world,
saw yet another video of a man
being murdered in cold blood
and rose up.
People all over the world
took to the streets
because they believe that
black people deserve
better treatment
than we have been getting.
[ Breathes sharply ]
And, you know, I'm not like,
"Oh, wow, everything's over.
Everything is fixed."
But...y'all, I am so shocked
that so many people showed up
for black people.
We've been being discriminated
against for fun for years,
and I didn't think
people cared or saw
or they knew
and were fine with it.
For whatever reason,
everyone is fed up, thank God.
And last night,
Obama held a town hall,
and he talked
about a comprehensive plan
with real policies
that can start saving lives
right now.
He talked about easy things
that every police force
in America
can choose to do this second
and start saving lives
this minute.
[ Breathes sharply ]
This change, if they enact it,
would be great.
But please don't forget
that it cost us
not only George Floyd's life,
but the lives of 11 people
who have been killed
during these protests,
including David McAtee...
Dave Patrick Underwood...
Chris Beaty...
Dorian Murrell...
Italia Kelly...
Calvin Horton Jr...
Javar Harrell...
Victor Cazares...
Sean Monterrosa...
David Dorn...
and from my hometown
of Omaha, Nebraska,
the brave James Scurlock.
Don't let it cost more lives.
Vote.
[Bleep]
I don't want to do it again.
Vote.
Call your representatives.
Unfriend racists.
And most importantly,
when you see something,
say something.
Do something.
Get loud.
Don't let people get away
with racist crap -- not anymore.
It's a new day.